Whenever a question comes to mind.
Search is one of the first places we turn to Google search has fundamentally
changed the way we access information, but how much do we really know about it?
We partnered with Google and invited someone from the search team to speak with
her viewers so that we could ask them anything.
Thanks to Google for sponsoring this episode.
My name is Danny Sullivan. I am Google's public liaison for search.
I worked within our search team to help foster two-way communications with
people who are outside of Google and bring some of the questions and interests
and issues that they may raise back into our search team.
And I'm super excited to answer a lot of the questions people have today. Hi,
I'm Ben. Nice to meet you. Thanks for coming with some questions today.
First question is,
is there someone on the other side judging my search history?
No.
Yes. When I first came to Google, I was asking about something and I said,
well here, I just did this. Can you do that again? So I can't. And he's like,
I literally can't look at that because it's your private information.
I don't have the ability to access that. There's no group of people going.
That's a big relief.
Good, good, good. So, so feel free to, to search your way.
How do you decide what's most important?
It helps if I talk maybe a little bit about the parts of a, of a search engine.
So we go out and we visit pages across the internet.
You store them like sort of a big book of the internet and kind of crawl through
that book and pick out the pages of relevant and different things we use to,
to rank out some of those pages.
If you were to take the index and all the pages that we have found,
I think our statistic is it might go to the moon 12 times and back, Oh wow.
Those are cat videos. And we make use of what we call signals.
Like what other words in the document, how do people link to this page?
Are those good quality links?
Is this page super loaded down with a bunch of ads and popups.
This is page load really quickly on a mobile device.
We put that all together and then that's how we,
we decide what seems to be the most relevant thing to show.
It's really like, cool. It's so fast. Yeah.
What happens to my search? Is it something that's saved?
Does it go to an ether?
If you're searching with a Google account,
then it'll be stored into your search history.
You have the option to go through and say, I want to delete out all.
If you really, really want to, you can just use Google incognito.
One of the things I think it was really excited about like six months or so ago,
we rolled it out.
So you could automatically delete your search history so that you would say
after three months, or I think the other one is after 18 months,
just automatically delete all this stuff. We don't want to keep it going.
And then I think the other part that's important as well.
Why have that information? And the reason we use it for Google searches,
because it will let us make better search results for you. Yeah.
If you walked into a library and you went backpack, right.
Like, okay. Um, you know, and they would have a conversation with you.
We don't kind of have that opportunity,
but we do have the opportunity when you do a series of searches.
So it's sort of out of.
So they kind of like connect the dots for the searches that you make.
And then my second question is, do they track your conversations?
Like when you say stuff,
when I'm talking and like my phone's off and I see ads of something,
exactly thing, like, is that true or no?
And it happened to me before as well. And you're like, Oh, how did that happen?
And it's like, no, I'll speak for Google. It's really not.
You got to push something or do something to send us what you're talking about.
Like, you use the wake word, then the wake word will transmit that back to us.
And it's just not going out there and just, you know,
constantly transmitting a stream of information back.
Wouldn't be that useful anyway. Right.
Pandemic change. They use her behavior. Yeah.
Yes. Um, wow. Did it ever,
we'd never seen so many searches for a single topic or a
sustained period of time. So at first it's like, what are the symptoms of it?
And then it's like what our treatments and what our testing centers.
And then it's, what's open. How do I make a stay at home gym?
How do I make sourdough bread? It's changed. Um,
know the way we've had to react to try to make sure we're getting all the best
information out there, response for people.
It's like, we're all,
there's like a kind of union in a kind of set away. Right?
We're all together.
It's definitely been so much sadness that there's also been,
I think a lot of hopefulness and in the way,
a lot of people have unified and carried on and found ways to keep going.
I feel like the country is in such a polarizing time now.
So I guess one example I'm thinking of is getting the flu shot.
There are people who say it can help prevent COVID-19 and there are people who
say it gives you a greater chance of it.
If someone had previously looked things up related to, for example,
the anti-vaccination side of it,
would it be more difficult for them to find something that could possibly change
their mind?
No, it shouldn't be more difficult at all.
So what you're referring to sometimes gets termed as a filter bubble.
So it's like, you've looked at all this information.
And so now you're going to get more information that aligns with say your,
your preconceived view.
A lot of people think that the search results for every individual are super
personalized. They're not, they're really not.
You're really going to get the same information. It's not going to change.
I think one of the reasons why people sometimes get confused is because
sometimes two different people can see very different results for the same
search. That's not personalization where it happens.
That's almost always localization. You said you were in Canada, is that right?
Yep, exactly. Yeah. If we both searched for pizza places,
we're going to get different results.
You don't want to know the best pizza places in a city.
That's a hundred miles away from you. So people can sometimes see that and go,
Oh, my road salts are much different because they,
they personalize them and he's like, no, no. Um, that's why it's.
My second question is a big, um, can.
The algorithm determine the difference between fact and fiction and
if not, does that worry you a little bit?
Um, so no account human beings can't even figure that out.
Sometimes she's like really complicated, but to the broader point,
it's really that people want to be able to search for things and know that
they're getting good, reliable information. And we think so. We hope so. And we,
we certainly do our best to show the most reliable information we can.
Yeah. After all you guys are a search engine, you're not like the fact checkers.
Right. So it makes sense.
Yes. But we do do a lot of work to try to make sure we are surfacing good,
like fact checking.
Sometimes if you search for something and we surface a fact check,
we can even have it tell you like true or false, according to that fact checker.
So one thing I want to know is can the algorithm be racist?
So the algorithm is not designed to be racist. The web,
just like society as a whole can have racist or problematic content that's
on it. That doesn't mean that we just say, well,
that is what's out there. And that's why it happens.
And that's our excuse.
That's really more to explain why it can sometimes happen.
There's always the chance that you could possibly do some kind of a search that
might bring forward. What,
what sometimes called a data void this referred to the idea that there's not
really good content. That's written about a particular topic.
Yeah. I mean, are there any concrete examples where, you know,
racism in the world was influencing what was naturally maybe getting aggregated
and you guys had a course corrected.
There's one good example. It's been very public that we talked about,
which was a few years ago. Uh, if you searched for that, the Holocaust happened.
We would tend to list a lot of Holocaust denial sites.
It was quite simply because it's such a known fact that
authorities were not writing content saying yes, the Holocaust happened.
One of the things that we learned from that was that we needed to do a better
job of understanding in cases where we don't have good,
reliable information that maybe we need to go beyond just the
exact order of the words and the exact phrasing of the words and go more into
the concept. So that,
that of surfacing content that is that the Holocaust happened. No,
it didn't happen as denial content. You're surfacing more content about,
say the Holocaust in general.
And then that helps people better understand the whole concept. Overall.
I'm finding that I'm spending a lot of time on Google these days,
especially leading up to the election,
just trying to understand the issues and candidates and all of that.
Do you think that the search engine algorithm can contribute to political
polarization? That's kind of occurring sometimes in the States.
We hope that they don't,
our systems don't understand that any kind of content has any political leaning
or political qualifications. Like we don't know,
like that's a left leaning page or a right-leaning page.
Our sisters also don't understand when someone's searching,
if they have kind of political leads.
So we don't have any of the ingredients to polarize. If we wanted to,
in the first place,
we really believed that there should be a commonality in the search results.
And that really our goal is to try to show everybody the best information and
most reliable information we can.
And hopefully if people take from that and they make their own decisions and
they'd look at a variety of information from a variety of resources and come to
their own conclusions from that,
I always wanted to know how does the auto-complete feature on Google work?
Because so many times it's freakishly close to what I'm actually thinking at the
basic level we're going through and trying to predict what's likely that
you're going to type next based on all the searches that we've seen before.
It saves, we figure about 25% of the time that you would normally spend typing.
And I think we even calculated one stat that like all the time savings is like
200 years of typing saved up each day.
Also mentioned by the way that we won't always just show the,
the most common searches that happen.
But we won't show things that we think might be harmful or perhaps derogatory,
or that might be advancing stereotypes with soda feels a good thing that I
guess, um, there's a lot of people in the world that think like me.
So that sort of makes the world a bit smaller.
It totally resonated to me when you say I don't feel low because it was exactly
how I felt. I think I remarked to my wife and the cashier, like, Oh,
we're not the only ones about that character or who are.
Do you think having access to so much information increases anxiety,
especially in young adults or young people?
Um, I hope not.
I don't think it should make you anxious that you have access to lots of
information. I think if you're better informed,
you should make you less anxious. You know,
hopefully sometimes it's pretty straightforward information. Like, you know,
I want to buy a suitcase sometimes it's like,
I need to get to an earthquake shelter or a hurricane shelter,
or I need to understand if I have a symptom or something.
I love that. Especially like now you're not limited to learning just in school.
Google really does help educate people and like get them resources that they
wouldn't be able to get as immediately.
One thing I would say is that it's not, I think so much that we're educating,
but the latter part of what you said, get you to the resources and information.
And ultimately it's really that people educate themselves or they have great
teachers or they have great people who support them and brought them up.
So it's nice that we're complimentary, we're part of that overall process.
Yeah. Critical thinking is,
is like essential to live in a society like this because we will never know.
Yeah. Well, it was very, very nice to meet you. Thank you so much.
Nice meeting you, Danny. This has been a, uh, it's been a highlight of my month,
you know, who talks to anybody anymore, right? I mean,
you're talking about like, it's all new people.
I will say hi to you in my next Google search.
I won't see it because of privacy.
They good humans.
Thank you so much for watching this video and thanks to Google for,
with us and sponsoring.
This episode.
I literally use Google for everything from fact checking statements to
seeing that chinchillas could eat paper. No thank you, Danny,
for hanging out with us and answering some challenging questions as always,
please don't forget to like comment, subscribe and check on our other.
Ask me anything videos where we give you an in-depth look on different people
and topics. Stay safe, everyone.